[Musique]
on va plus loin avec un livre à grand
reporter de guerre indépendante bonjour
anne bonjour ça vous bruno daroux de la
rédaction de france 24 bon jour où nos
bons jours à peine la russie jette
semble-t-il toutes ses forces dans la
bataille pour la conquête du donbass
cette région de l'est de l'ukraine
rester dans un climat de quasi guerre
civile depuis 2000 14 ou des milices
séparatistes milite activement pour
l'invasion russe est en proie à des
combats d'une intensité maximale d'après
les autorités ukrainiennes qui
s'estiment largement dépassé sur place
en hommes et en moyens écoutez la vice
ministre ukrainienne de la défense tu
vis du président céline ski
la situation reste difficile et montre
des signes d'aggravation
l'ennemi à utiliser toutes ses forces et
tous ses moyens pour s'emparer de notre
territoire est encerclée nos troupes
les combats ont atteint leur intensité
maximale
les forces armées ukrainiennes nos
services de renseignement et tous ceux
qui défendent le pays résistait une
offensive extrêmement féroce à l'est par
endroits l'ennemi est considérablement
supérieure en équipements et en nombre
de soldats soldate
vous il ya trois semaines pour
l'hebdomadaire le point la russie est
elle en passe d'après vous de pouvoir
revendiquer sa première victoire
d'ampleur dans cette guerre
vous allez un peu fort là je pense que
la première victoire que la russie
réclame c'est d'abord ce qu'elle a déjà
acquis depuis le 24 février c'est à dire
ne l'oublions pas on en parle assez peu
mais la halle à l'avancé est clair
depuis la crimée jusqu'à cette ville
personne qui est la ville du sud du sud
au sud une basse qu'elle a prises dans
les premiers jours et qu'elle a gardée
depuis et dans laquelle aujourd'hui on
est en train voilà on l'envoie à carson
au nord de la crimée voyez donc au sud
de l'ukraine cette ville elle est prise
et tout ce qui est en rouge là c'est
déjà pris donc c'est quand même déjà pas
mal surtout le sud s'étaient pas pris
ans le 24 février alors que tout ce qui
est laid cela en rouge c'était déjà ces
mêmes positions à peu près depuis
2014 depuis le début de la guerre dans
le dos de bath mais ce que la russie
veut faire à ce que les troupes russes
veulent faire c'est justement
encerclé voyez le petit morceau presque
rond au milieu du rouge la severodonezk
rama torse qui sont des villes où
j'étais il ya encore quelques semaines
la russie souhaiterait les prendre c'est
à dire que le rouge avancé que ce soit
finalement une ligne plus stable mais il
n'y arrive pas la grande villa c'est ce
verrou donetsk qu'il faut encerclé il
faut d'abord l'encercler et ensuite il
faut lutter à l'intérieur pour la
prendre pour le moment ils sont pas ils
sont apportés importés de deux tirs de
mortier sont importés tir mortier
absolument mais ça ça s'appelle juste la
guerre c'est les positions position
contre position artillerie contre a
retiré mais ça veut pas dire vous avez
vu le temps qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
acquises dont ils ont besoin pour mario
paul en face ce qui frappe 1 bruno
daroux c'est la détermination des
ukrainiens à résister ils n'entendent
rien concéder à la russie non c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs que les russes mettent
autant de temps à progresser que c'est
très lent que c'est très dur que c'est
compliqué parce qu'en face effectivement
il ya non seulement l'armée et craignant
l ukrainienne mais il ya aussi les
forces de défense territoriale comme
vous l'avez dit qu'ils sont très
présentes quand même et puis à
l'armement
qui arrive même si on sent bien que
c'est quand même sur une ligne de crête
puisque les déclarations qu'on a entendu
des dirigeants ukrainiens à l'instant
montre que notamment quand sa lancée
vers audonienne ce qu'ils auraient
besoin des réclames il révéla voilà
l'islam voulue notamment les les
les battre les véhicules qui envoient
des plusieurs roquettes ce qu'on se
recrée russe voilà les roquettes
multiples et qui les utilise très
fortement alors les russes ils sont se
sont effectivement retirée de kharkiv
alors ça c'est l'autre va en parler mais
il leur stratégie c'est toujours un peu
ce qu'on appelait leur deuxième guerre
mondiale la stratégie du chaudron c'est
à dire que on encercle on pilonne on
pilonne ont détruit quasiment la ville
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait à marioupol
c'est ce que visiblement il commence à
faire ac 0-2 niet et puis un moment
effectivement les civils s'en vont où se
rendent et les combattants maïs ronde où
ils sont tués anne vous qui avez connu
grozny rasé y at-il un risque
aujourd'hui de voir ces verdonnais subir
le même sort que mario paul un côté
j'espère pas parce que c'est une
catastrophe mais effectivement c'est la
falla façon comme bien de qui vient
d'être décrite de pilonnages de l'armée
russe mais là on est en nous autres
commentateurs en studio on aimerait que
enfin on voudrait que nos commentaires
soient claires parce que ici mais si nos
commentaires étaient claires ça voudrait
dire qu'il ya des changements clair sur
le terrain or c'est plus compliqué que
ça avant d'arriver à encercler ses
vérins dan yates je vous rappelle qu'il
y a quelques semaines il s'est passé
quand même quelque chose de notable qui
est l'échec total des forces militaires
russes a traversé la frontière de
daniels ils ont perdu là ils voulaient
encercler ses verdonnaise déjà depuis
plusieurs semaines simplement il avait
tenté un encerclement plus large il
avait créé ce pont flottant vous savez
vous vous souvenez il ya eu 400 morts
russe quand même donc cette rivière de
dan yates c'est une frontière naturelle
et elle ralentit l'arrivée des russes
sur severino dos qu'aujourd'hui et pour
le moment ils se sont résolus donc un
encerclement plus petit mais c'est la
grande question c'est une mise une fois
qu'ils auront encerclé c'est à dire prix
de pris de court les forces militaires
ukrainienne il va y avoir du combat
urbain c'est là on pourra éventuellement
comparé à mario paul ou pas on voit en
tout cas le narratif côté craignent un
bruno qui clairement là depuis 48 heures
donne dans quelque chose de beaucoup
plus grave que beaucoup plus grave parce
que visiblement les russes ont décidé de
mettre le paquet sur ce verrou de niet
et puis de reprendre en reparler donc le
pilonnage de kharkiv où ils ont été
dégagés récemment mais donc il ya un
sentiment d'urgence en tout cas parce
qu'il ya trop de pression et ils sentent
que là c'est vraiment 50 50 donc c'est
pour ça qu'ils réclament à cor et à cri
ces armements mais alors certaines
certaines de ces armes sont arrivés il y
a aussi deux jours dans les ukrainiens
ont montré les fameux canons caesar de
la france me fait un clip où disait
merci france et s était écrit donc ils
reçoivent certains de ses équipements
militaires mais face quand même à une
armée qui ont dit beaucoup que l'armée
russe a failli sur tel ou tel point
enfin en termes d'équipement et
d'effectifs ça reste quand même une
armée très importante sur place vous
avez observé voinea le sentiment l'état
d'esprit des populations il varie venant
considérablement d'un lieu à l'autre on
n'est pas toujours fermement opposé à la
présence russe
c'est paula question s'est pas opposé ou
pas poser c'est comment peut-on quelle
est la perception des habitants locaux
de 2 comment ils pourraient mieux vivre
finalement donc c'est pas clair quand il
ya une guerre mais étant donné que la
les troupes qui envahissent l'ukraine
sont des troupes russes qui parlent la
même langue que la population qui habite
le donne basse le donbass ukrainien tout
le monde y parle russe la population et
russophone beaucoup plus que dans
l'ouest de l'ukraine il y a d'abord une
lassitude de la guerre ça on la voit
dans tous les conflits et là elle arrive
déjà c'est à dire que les gens disent
finalement pour que ça s'arrête c'est
pas grave si c'est les russes qu'ils
contrôlent
mais et comme de toute façon se sont
passées par la population civile qui
décide ce sont les politiques et les
militaires sur le terrain et là on a
quand même de narrative différent on
allait les politiques qui comme bruno
vient de le dire ne cesse de réclamer
plus d'armes et l ess qui a parlé à
davos a parlé au festival de cannes pour
dire toujours la même chose et pour
finalement tirer toujours la sonnette
d'alarmé dire qu'on n'en fait pas assez
et puis on a les militaires l'ukrainien
qui eux parlent peu est-ce que vous avez
déjà vu une interview du chef
d'état-major y en a pas parce qu'il est
occupé à résister sur le terrain et là
on est plutôt dans une guerre longue
avec des positions justement
d'artillerie qui sont un peu ou prou les
mêmes depuis 2014 dans le dôme basse et
qui trinquent bien sûr c'est la
population civile
surprise ou peut-être pas d'ailleurs un
bruno en tout cas les russes ont
bombardé kharkiv un objectif qu'ils
avaient semblé délaissé au début du mois
oui alors il avait semblé décès parce
qu'ils ont ils ont dû faire face à une
forte contre offensive ukrainienne dont
ils se sont retirés mais il s'en
trouvera la carte d'ailleurs un oui
voilà prendre un set au nord ouest au
nord-est bateau nord-est et ouest
de l'ukraine ces grandes villes voilà
c'est la deuxième voie la voie la plus
grande ville
voilà on a l'impression qu'en fait les
russes se disent que puisque leur
objectif initial de conquérir toute
l'ukraine a échoué en fait donc il ya ce
premier effectivement un petit rond
entre de severodonetsk pour finaliser
certains l'encerclement il a parachevé
la prise du dombass a devancé limites
administratives à l'ukrainienne en
quelque sorte d'une part et si possible
d'étendre sa part une ligne kharkiv qui
rejoindrait le sud du pays ce qui ferait
là qu'il prendrait un peu le un grand
test si vous voulez qu'ils tombent
dessus mais c'est que c'est compliqué on
n'est pas là un bon voilà on y est pas
mais mais l'objectif visiblement c'est
ça ce serait de s'emparer là d'une bonne
partie du territoire mais effectivement
ils sont pas comment vous interprétiez
beaucoup de résistance comment vous
interpréter ce bombardement de kharkiv 1
est-ce que c'est comme lui vous de temps
en temps il va aller les russes vont
continuer à se rappeler au bon venir
entre guillemets des populations ou bien
il ya véritablement un objectif à terme
de prise de cette ville écoute je ne
suis pas dans la tête des militaires
russes en tout cas ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que non le bombardement de
kharkiv n'a rien à voir avec les
bombardements épisodique de lviv qui est
même pas sur la carte là qui est bien
plus à l'ouest proche de la pologne donc
kharkiv ses actifs c'est véritablement
la deuxième plus grande ville d'ukraine
après kiev et c'est une ville qui a
failli être prises là par les russes il
ya quelques semaines ils étaient aux
abords de réactifs et donc une contre
offensive plusieurs petites contre
offensive réussie ukrainienne les ont
buté les ont fait reculer jusqu'à leurs
frontières russes piste car qui sait la
plume d'une très grande ville
ukrainienne proche de la frontière russe
mais aujourd'hui tout simplement
pourquoi pourquoi elle est bombardé les
bombarder parce que les russes
considèrent qu'ils n'en ont pas fini
avec art qui fait parce que leur but
même si on n'est pas dans leur tête
c'est de effectivement causé du tort
c'est de ces de semer la déroute c'est
de semer le chaos donc ne peuvent le
faire ils continuent à le faire
souhaitons que la vie avait repris un
cours normal à 15 jours 1 voilà et bleu
métro avait repris la vraie la vie dans
la guerre ne cesse jamais ça c'est une
erreur de croire que la vie s'arrête la
vie ne s'arrête jamais vous nous l'avez
soit visuellement râpé mais le mend le
bon peuple sa dalle rompu à ravir et
éviter absolument mais les habitants
sont pas sortir
oui mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
de toute façon les villes ne sont jamais
morte il ya toujours des habitants qui
sont là et qui continue à vivre malgré
tout donc les russes continuent à
pilonner ils ont aucune raison d'arrêter
je crois que ce qui serait important
aujourd'hui d'essayer de comprendre
c'est quand les deux parties vont elles
saisir l'opportunité avoir la volonté de
négocier par maintenant vision le mettre
à négocier puisque la russie vient de
rejeter un plan de paix italiens alors
qu'il prévoyait
free a notamment une souveraineté du de
préserver sur la crimée et le don de
base c'est ça qu'ils sont bien
accueillis avec une autonomie renforcée
et de ces territoires mais effectivement
ce n'est acceptable ni pour la russie
parce qu'on a quand même l'impression
que même si tout cela a été très
compliqué beaucoup plus compliquée que
ce qu'escomptaient vladimir poutine on a
quand même l'impression que l'objectif
final demeure quand même la
neutralisation de toute l'ukraine ce
quel que soit le temps que ça prendra en
moi en année on ne sait pas mais on n'a
pas l'impression que la détermination de
l'avenir poutine soit amoindrie et puis
en face les ukrainiens qui eux du coup
comme ils sont agressés qu'ils défendent
leur terre n'ont pas envie pour le
moment de concéder des parties de
territoires supplémentaires à la russie
et même sur le statut des deux provinces
pro-russe du donbass et de la crimée
parfois ils disent même alors c'est un
peu mou vent à leur position mais parce
qu'ils disent même qu'ils veulent que ce
soit à nouveau totalement sous
souveraineté ukrainienne ça fluctue ça
fluctue effectivement les propos du
rapport de force et voilà il peut il
s'est remis à dire récemment lors d'une
interview que la la guerre que ça serait
difficile d'avoir une victoire claire ce
qu'il ne dit pas toujours et qu' il
faudrait peut-être
redessiner les cartes et je vous
rappelle il ya aussi henry kissinger
l'ancien secrétaire d'état américain qui
soit 98
oui qui a dit hier je crois aux états
unis que il serait peut-être bon de
revenir au statu quo ante et c'est à
dire celui juste avant le 24 février
2022 alors évidemment il ya une levée de
boucliers en ukraine mais en europe tous
nos leaders politiques ne sont pas
d'accord vous avez ou c'est quand même
emmanuel macron qui lui également et
salaires des plus proches d'une ligne où
il faudrait négocier quelques solutions
plutôt que d'aller jusqu'au bout et le
problème c'est pour le moins on n'a pas
les deux parties n'arrivent est
absolument pas à se mettre d'accord sur
le contenu de planifier le groupe plus
politique d'une négociation c'est pour
ça que les militairement parlant ça ça
continue des deux côtés à dire va avoir
une rhétorique de dire qu'il faut aller
jusqu'au bout on va peut-être en un mot
même si c'est un sujet avec qui
certainement nous auquel nous consacrons
des émissions et nombreuses
malheureusement dans le futur mais cette
question de la crise alimentaire
mondiale aujourd'hui moscou accusé par
les occidentaux de tenir en otage d'une
certaine manière les marchés notamment
être le blocus de ses ports ukrainiens
qui empêche du coup les céréales de
partir bruno est ce qu'il ya des moyens
aujourd'hui qui sont envisagées pour
permettre le départ de ces cargaisons
alors les abonnements vers l'allemagne
déjà comment oui par le faire revient
voilà par le ferroviaire mais c'est
compliqué parce qu'on plus très
prosaïquement il ya un problème d
d'écartement des rails qui n'est pas le
même en ukraine et de l'autre côté de la
frontière côté polonais par exemple donc
ça que ça complique les opérations et
puis par exemple à odessa donc il n'a
pas été conquis par les russes mais les
russes contrôlent la mer noire eh bien
il ya 20 millions de tonnes de céréales
qui sont dans leurs silos qui sont
stockés là bas qui sont bloqués et
évidemment ça a un impact sur les pays
qui en consomment beaucoup notamment
dans le sud de la méditerranée le
maghreb la libye le liban dans qui sont
très dépendants donc ça commence
évidemment à créer des situations
alimentaire extrêmement tendue alors il
ya un pays qui essaye de jouer les
médiateurs sans succès pour l'instant
c'est la turquie puisqu'elle contrôle
les deux d'efforts voilà les deux des
trois el dib ont essayé de vous mettre
d'accord russe et ukrainien pour
permettre à ces céréales ukrainien de
sortir mais cela dit il faut aussi dire
que tout ce qui se passe là le fait que
à la mer noire ne soit ne soit plus
libre de circulation si vous voulez ça
complique aussi la faire pour les
céréales russes plus les sanctions qui
touchent des des histoires de logistique
des flux financiers donc les céréales
russes aussi ne peuvent s'analyser aussi
contrairement à ce qu'a dit vladimir
poutine aujourd'hui en disant on
continue d'exporter notre bhl extérieur
c'est aussi compliqué pour les céréales
russes et le total juste un dernier mot
de céréales russes et connaissez un
tiers des besoins mondiaux en blé donc à
terme de la mènera un problème énorme ça
peut être un nouveau front économique
dont le front militaire qui joue du
chantage alimentaire
de larmes alimentaire vladmir poutine
d'après vous il est prêt à femmes et la
planète où c'est pas du tout ni son
intention d'y son intérêt
je ne sais pas vraiment quelles sont ses
intentions mais en tout cas dans les
faits et effectivement il est on peut on
peut parler de chantage tout à fait il
est clair que les déclarations venir
poutine et il le dire il le dit calme si
vous lever les sanctions celle de cesser
de ses autres officiel depuis hier ils
ont trouvé cette idée ils ont trouvé ce
filon de finalement ils se disent ça
serait peut-être une possibilité pour
nous de commencer à ne plus avoir ces
sanctions etc c'est une autre façon de
mener la guerre finalement c'est une
autre façon aussi peut-être de négocier
comme il n'arrive pas à négocier les uns
avec les autres finalement cette
obligation de continuer ce développement
économique mondiale tant côté ukrainien
que côté russe les obligeraient et il
fait peur à tout le monde et les
obligeraient finalement à trouver un
consensus donc c'est pour ça qu'ils en
profitent ce sera peut-être d'ailleurs
là l'une des voies de sortie de crise
merci beaucoup à denis va d'avoir été
avec nous merci également à vous bruno
c'était on va plus loin on se retrouve
93 minutes pour un nouveau genre
[Musique]